- And it all starts
with one of television's
favorite couples.
She's been a newscaster for
nearly every major network
since the 70's, and he
is the longest running
daytime host out there.
He is just retiring after
a whopping 31 seasons.
I love that it, not at 30, he was like,
"I wanna do one extra."
(audience laughs)
I'm gonna just make it special.
And if you wanna know who the
father is, he probably knows.
So, when I hung out with, get it?
So when I hung out with Connie
Chung, I'm just a comedian,
Connie Chung and Maury Povich
when we were in New York,
and I had to ask one of
the most obvious questions.
So, take a look.
Wait, so Maury, like how often do people,
I have to know this,
how often in New York do
people just shout out,
"You are the father."
- All the time.
(Audience laughs)
- 'Cause I would be one of those tools.
- Well, you know,
everybody says, you know,
"What is it like, you know,
people, you know, yell,
"you are the father" or
"I'm not the father.""
And I said look, "How would
you like to walk around
New York City and nobody
knew who you were?
What does that mean?
It means your shows not working."
- Yeah. Oh, yeah.
- I mean, I don't know how
you feel about this Kelly,
but I know some friends
of mine in the business,
they don't like to converse
with people, they don't like
to sign autographs and things like that.
And I'm saying to myself,
"Are you kidding this is why
you're successful.
You're successful because of them,
you're not successful-"
- Yeah, and sometimes it's
their moment, you know.
(Audience clapping)
It's like, I get like privacy
to a point, or something
like if you're having
dinner or something, like
"Do you mind waiting until after,
and then I'll do whatever."
But like, its also you have to think,
I've had this conversation with friends,
actually fellow coaches on The Voice,
and its like, its their one
moment, maybe, to see you,
and their excited.
So like, just lean in, you know?
- I saw an Instagram thing
of The Rock the other day
and he was driving in his neighborhood,
and this tour bus coming around,
and he stopped, he waved,
they took pictures,
they were doing selfies.
And he was just in his neighborhood.
- I love that!
He was like, "yep, my
house is right there."
(Audience laughing)
That's amazing!
Wait, so how annoying is
it for you hearing that?
"I am not the".
Do you yell out, "Original", like.
- No, I said, "He's not my baby daddy."
(Audience laughing)
- He was not the father.
Oh my God, I love you two!
So, Maury, people also like to remix
your daddy announcements like this one.
We're showing this.
Tell me you want to be on the Maury show
without telling me you want
to be on the Maury show.
- [Maury] When it comes
to one year old Isaiah,
Amir, you are not the father.
(Audience cheering)
- Oh yeah.
- I love that.
- [Kelly} I love that.
- I do too.
- I'm big on TikTok.
I mean, they do all kinds of things.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, you are a hit.
Oh my god, I love those dogs.
They're like, "Wait, what?"
- What!
- All right, well, you
you settle conflicts
on your show, but in marriage,
what's the key to settling a fight?
Cause you've done well.
- Well, no, no, no. Hold on.
- Its a fight.
- [Maury] We have different views of this.
- [Connie] Yeah.
- Okay.
- See, I believe that its worked
because we don't see each
other much during the day,
and then when we have some
discussions, arguments,
when the head hits the pillow, its over.
Its never, ever, ever, it
never goes on the next morning.
Never.
- [Kelly] Oh, really.
- No.
I hold a grudge.
And the next morning, I want it continued.
I'm not done.
- I was not finished, Sir.
- Yeah.
- And you know, he's not
like the guy he is on TV.
On TV, if you know, they
can scream, they can cry,
they can go nuts.
And, you know,
he's so calm, so comforting.
Just holds people's hands and everything.
But when he gets home,
I say, "Do you know what happened today?"
And he goes, "I don't
wanna hear about it."
- I've heard enough today.
I can't take your crap, I
had enough chaos happening.
- [Connie] Exactly.
- Yeah, but its worked, I mean it's.
- Yeah.
- 37, I think, 37 years.
- Well, you know what?
- Wow! 37 years?
Congratulations!
(Audience clapping)
- That's a long time.
- It is a long time,
it's a really long time.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's great. Yeah.
- [Maury] Yeah.
- [Kelly] I love it!
- [Maury] Backstage, one
of your social media people
were asking us our
favorite songs and I said,
"Well, one of them for me is,
You Can't Always Get What You Want."
And she says, "That's true."
(Audience laughing)
- See I think humor and I also think like,
its cool that you-
- [Maury] Humor is important.
- Humor is important, but
also that you said that
you go and you do your
things during the day.
You know you do have
alone time, a little bit.
I think that's cool.
- [Connie] Oh yeah, no, no, I-
- [Kelly] You have your own lives as well.
- She doesn't want to see me.
- To me, you cannot spend time together.
- That is the key. Never see them.
You heard it here, folks.
- Not even on vacations.
No, we see each other a lot.
- He's a crazy golfer, you know-
- Yeah.
- In that, you know,
he's gone for many hours.
- Yeah.
- And the best part, those
wives who allow you to do it.
- Oh my God.
Here's the thing, like,
you should, though.
People should have like
their own time to do their,
that's, yeah.
- You know what the last
thing a golf widow does
before she has sex?
- I love you so much, I don't.
- She drops her husband off at the course.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
(drum sting)
(Audience cheering)
- Brrm.
- Oh my God, Connie.